[Applauso]
se fotografia uno sconosciuto nel
momento esatto in cui parte la tendina
quella persona smette di esser di uno
sconosciuto e tela porterai dietro per
sempre
sarà sempre con te buonasera mi chiamo
damiano andreotti faccio il fotografo e
non o concetti alti da esporvi questa
sera voglio solo condividere con voi un
progetto di ritratti
io ho sempre avuto una venerazione per
quella che è l'arte del ritratto
però mi sono approcciato tardi a livello
di carriera perché secondo me tutta la
parte di fotografia che riguarda il
ritratto prevede una maturità sia
stilistica che tecnica molto molto molto
alta non che io l'abbia raggiunta per
carità però diciamo ci provo ecco il
progetto si chiama il volto riflesso
dell'anima è un progetto dove l'estetica
del soggetto passa in secondo piano
quello che mi interessa fotografare è la
storia è il vissuto del soggetto che
davanti e cercare di immortalarlo
proprio mentre mista in maniera
silenziosa raccontando una storia
ho fotografato gente
nota al grande pubblico meno nota gente
normale e anche gente sconosciuta
ok
fotografare legge le persone normali per
persone normali intendo tutte quelle
persone che non sono abituate a stare su
un set che non sono abituate a stare sul
palcoscenico salgono sul set è la prima
cosa che cominciano a dirti alla
velocità della luce in maniera ansiogena
è allora le mani dove le metto le
come mi metto cosa faccio no guarda non
riprendermi di lì perché poi mi si
vedono le orecchie a sventola
quando riesco a fermare questo flusso
incontrollato di paure io chiedo a loro
un aggettivo per favore di descriversi
con un aggettivo solo serve a me per
riuscire a capire per avere delle chiavi
perché quello che a me serve in un
progetto il ritratto è semplicemente
avere delle chiavi di lettura
a quel punto loro mi dicono un aggettivo
allora io chiedo a loro di concentrarsi
molto intensamente su una storia su una
storia che ha cambiato la loro vita che
è il frutto di quell'aggettivo e allora
gli chiedo di concentrarsi sui colori
sui profumi sui suoni sulla musica che
stava andando in quel particolare
momento saranno all'aperto se faceva
freddo
allora in quel momento lì se riesci a
portare il soggetto realmente
all'interno del suo pensiero la posa
viene da sola
cominciano a formarsi delle
microespressioni sul volto del soggetto
tutto funziona tutto è incastrato e
l'unica cosa che che mi basta fare
scattare scattare nel momento nel
momento giusto
il setup che uso per le per le immagini
è molto semplice nel senso uso una luce
sola e un fondo nero perché l'unico
protagonista del mio scatto non deve
essere la uno sfoggio di tecnica non
deve essere
l'inquadratura ricercata le mille cose
di scenografia voglio la faccia voglio
la sua faccia che mi racconti la sua
storia e che esca dal fondo nero mi sono
fatto una scaletta perché sono mille
robbie e allora io tendenzialmente
lavoro a cavalletto perché quando riesco
a creare quell'empatia quel soggetto io
praticamente mi elimino dal set lo
lascio da solo nei suoi pensieri nelle
sue strutture
nel suo viaggio mentale mi nascondo
dietro il cavalletto e comincia una
sorta di tango emotivo con col soggetto
usa uno zoom per chi mastica un po di
fotografia e quindi mi mi avvicino
cercando un ritratto un primo piano
strettissimo mi allontano per dargli più
spazio e cerco sempre di mettere della
distanza tra me e il soggetto perché
voglio che sia il soggetto a stare con
se stesso perché abbia la possibilità di
raccontare non la sua estetica ma il suo
vissuto
poi si cominciano a leggere i soggetti
nel senso che ho fotografati davvero
tanti e si cominciano a leggere e le
chiavi di cui parlavo prima vengono
sempre più facili da trovare e quindi ci
sono soggetti che si nascondono per me
quello che avevo definito e che ogni
soggetto per me a una a una spada e a
uno scudo tutti i soggetti ce l'hanno
vuol dire che c'è uno scudo dietro a cui
si nascondono perché hanno paura di
mostrare determinate cose e hanno una
spada con la quale si difendono dal mio
occhio e quando trovi che possono essere
tipo nel dei soggetti femminili una cosa
che viene usata tantissimo sono i
capelli allora vengono usati per
nascondersi vengono usati per avere
forza per per cercare di avere
un atteggiamento magari più più deciso
più sensuale più arrabbiato li mettono
davanti li mettono dietro e quella roba
lì sono tutti elementi che per me non
hanno una valenza estetica hanno una
valenza di contenuto perché si arriva a
quel punto lì il il gioco cambia un po
quando ci si trova a fotografare persone
che sono abituate a stare sul set sono
persone che sono abituate a essere
fotografate per lavoro sono persone che
sono abituate a stare sul palcoscenico e
mostrarsi davanti a un sacco di gente
per me li lavora è stato un pochino più
difficile perché mi sono reso conto dopo
averne fotografati un paio che mi stavo
ritrovando con una bellissima collezione
di personaggi famosi ma neanche una
persona famosa perché alla fine il
personaggio tende a passare sopra la
persona ea me il personaggio non
interessa per questo tipo di progetto
allora tendenzialmente il fotografo che
si trova davanti a una persona
conosciuta a una star tende a come dire
far prevalere il suo ego per dire faccio
metto la mia firma su questa foto con le
pose con la roba allora si crea una una
battaglia ok tipo avete presente la
battaglia finale di star wars con le
spade laser caricate a dego perché leggo
e del fotografo cerca di sormontare
leggo dell'artista che a sua volta cerca
di sormontare leggo del fotografo e alla
fine io a quel gioco li ho deciso
neanche proprio di partecipare
io ho alzato le mani e ho detto va bene
fai quello che devi fare per me è questo
questo lavoro è un viaggio è un viaggio
vero e proprio perché
non chiamo le persone nel mio studio io
cerco di andare dalle persone a casa
loro
nel loro studio di registrazione nelle
loro città banalmente in zone franche
perché io mi metto nel ruolo del
dell'ospite e quindi il banalissimo
gesto di aprire la porta e farmi entrare
mi permette mi fa fare già un pezzettino
del lavoro che che devo fare
poi e quindi c'è tutta la ritualità del
caffè c'è la ritualità delloye un
bicchier dato quella romantica
a questo punto monto set e il set per me
è un limbo spazio temporale dove cerco
di raccogliere la maggior parte delle
informazioni che mi servono per
fotografare la persona e chiudere fuori
il personaggio è quindi molto scettico
sulle luci tiro sul fondo nero e intanto
si chiacchiera e mi danno degli
strumenti per riuscire a fare il mio
lavoro per riuscire a ottenere il
risultato che voglio fatto questo ci
sono poi dei casi che sono delle come
dire delle eccezioni ci sono stati degli
artisti che ho che ho avuto il piacere
fotografare talmente bravi che loro sono
on off nel senso al su alcuni ho giocato
sulla velocità di scatto
il mio 7 studiato alla perfezione nel
senso che per me il clan la classica
prova luci non esiste perché so
esattamente con che diaframma scattare
che in che modo di impostare le luci per
me non esiste e quindi vai sul set
tranquillo rilassati non ti preoccupare
facciamo solo delle prove per me quelli
tendenzialmente diciamo 8 volte su 10
sono gli scatti buoni e poi loro lo
fanno e cerco di essere velocissimo
faccio degli set da 34 minuti perché
dopo li la persona il personaggio la
persona normale chiunque
comincia a prendere confidenza con
questo posto che è il set
allora comincia a dire ma allora se
mette una mano in tasca
magari mi viene fuori la spalla mi si
vede un po di più il pettorale
e smette di pensare alle sue storie
smette di pensare realmente chi è
e mi sta vendendo il personaggio è il
personaggio non mi interessa e quelli
che sono assolutamente bravissimi
salgono sul set si spegne alla persona e
si accende il personaggio e cominciano a
fare le faccette cominciano a fare le
coppe
la faccia da copertina men's health
cominciano a fare quelle robe lì e non
mi interessa
allora li devo fare un grosso lavoro per
destrutturare devo riuscire a lavorare e
cercare il modo di dire al personaggio
scusa ma mi fai la stessa faccia di
quando eravamo davanti alla macchinetta
del caffè 12 minuti fa per favore però
quella roba lì è difficile per riuscire
a trovare e ci lavora in questo modo poi
a volte questo è il caso lui e kate
middleton che è il fondatore degli stomp
lui è arrivato è il super personaggio va
bene adesso mi metto di buzzo buono come
dicono a roma e smonto il tuo
personaggio
a un certo punto bisogna alzare bandiera
bianca quando ti accorgi che la persona
che hai davanti non è il personaggio ma
è proprio la sua esternazione di se
stesso senza filtri con fili senza avere
paura di quello che può essere il
pensiero della gente non non troppo
tempo fa ho fatto un lavoro in una
scuola ho portato questo progetto in una
scuola erano i primi scatti che avete
visto e quando riesci a scardinare a
trovare quella crepa che c'è
nell'armatura a infilarci dentro il
palatino e far saltare l'armatura il set
diventa quasi un luogo di sfogo di
confessione e quindi la gente arriva e
riesce a vendersi per quello che era
ragazzi che ti rechi mi raccontavano la
loro storia seguiti dal loro aggettivo
dicendomi le cose più intime del loro
essere e quello che mi ha veramente
fatto fatto bene e molto male è che non
abbassavano gli occhi dall'obiettivo
continuavano a raccontarmi la loro
storia
guardandomi nell'obiettivo poi ci sono
personaggi che fotografi in 36 scatti
riesco a fare 36 scatti e capisco di
avere la foto perché sono lì e dicono va
bene sono io
guardami 36 scatti e me ne vado a casa
in maniera pulita senza senza problemi
un dettaglio perché e scatto in bianco
nero non perché abbia problemi con il
bilanciamento del bianco semplicemente
scatto in bianco nero perché dicono che
se se scatti a colori un ritratto stai
scattando i vestiti della persona
se scatti in bianco e nero stai stai
scattando la sua la sua anima e quindi
poi ci si trova anche a dover lavorare
con con gli artisti che a tutte le volte
che tutte le volte vogliono che ci sia
qualcosa di loro
e a me piace perché il fatto di farli
trovare a casa ti permettono di lavorare
con una profondità decisamente maggiore
è molto molto bello io su queste
immagini qua chiuderei che si fanno un
più o meno si allora
io ve la chiudo così se nel mirino vedi
la persona lascia stare è il suo
pensiero che devi ritrarne
[Applauso]